ma se non sapete lo facciamo video
normale visto che è uscito residenti
vole basta volevo infatti non sono più
parlato volevo vedere se riuscivo a fare
un altro episodio di harry stickman
perché avete visto che l'ho già finito
c'è allora ci sono tutti finali da da
sbloccare non gli ho sbloccato per
niente tuttino fatti 67 anziché quindi
adesso vediamo se si possono fare allora
proviamo a fare governess support
presume di fare questa questa combo
perché questa gomma ancora non l'ho
fatta diamo in una baita il diamante
ruby è ok ok qualche hanno spiegato che
siamo sulla stazione
basta minchia chance ha neanche provato
carchio ecco le frasi come ci siamo
incrociati fao mi modo per arrivare allo
spazio come come fai che l'elicottero
non ci può andare via va bene cliccano
nel containment è male ma la roma
pensavo andasse dell'importo nome
l'elicottero sparare in aria o meno
principale che facciamo thrashball bimbo
thrashball polar immondizia va bene c'è
una palla di merda sostanzialmente
fatali discardi bello ha funzionato
niente perché parli non possono
cliccarlo fermi tutti è bello è stato
bellissimo ha fatto e poi mai
sono infatti solo di essere posto
charles pomarede tina bravo che si è
proceduto con lui allora non sbagliata
una quindi vediamo di riuscire a fare le
cose fatte bene ventosa e come non ci
passi là dentro
no sono cascato cassano fa vivo che io
credo che penso di essere morto da che
parte dove sono andati i loro ragazzi
[Musica]
ok
sapete che stiamo facendo raga merda
ma no mi muore charles gestore cardinale
mano a mano che brani ma dai
ma che cazzo abbiamo fatto siamo andati
là sopra per cosa devo andarci a
schiantarsi al tornati per via dei
genitori è morto charles capitale molto
cia scoli cubi o ragazze caso tutto
questo record facciamo charles cros
teammate un giorno prima del lancio ok a
sono arrivato che il treno è così
entrato in galleria ars del gruppo lando
nel treno tofas box sempre per rimanere
la metal gear style ed è invece treni
che gestisce i perfetto non controllate
la no mi hanno messo no ma rock and ice
qua dentro
bellissima cosa let's go home etiquette
ragazze questo per entrare in qualsiasi
posto avrebbe avuto senso però dire
l'altro cappello latina è nella
passaporta tale manichino window mi
siedo mi faccio il manichino che mia
merda farò sto male nostro gioco e
geniale regalaci hanno vinto tutto
quindi poi anche fuori dalla finestra
sono giustamente abbiamo cosa intenda
fare buttati fuori dalla finestra perché
sono rimasto sopra il treno abbassa di
questa galleria barba stati
oddio no vabbè dai e poi senza ciò che
ci piace trasforma ok seria schiere
perfin fatto ben due anni sono
impacchettato nel razzo minchia su cpac
[Musica]
recupero dei valori che tanto che se ne
fanno le prove di volo nello spazio ora
che ci penso manca la macchina apro la
mafia me ne vado giusto
berna è molto più facile del previsto
[Applauso]
la strada tutta libera hanno fatto
charles con tutto tranne che con
international rescue fammi vedere la
dose di coca non solo sì sono io perché
io faccio parte ancora dell'esercito e
mi stanno mandando non ricorrenti per a
buttare giù col cioè la madre wing a in
modo tale che sembri qualcosa che non
sia elicottero
c'è una luce o la nuvola quindi non c'è
niente perfetto che ha tra i jackpot
bellissimo invisible bridge fammelo
vedendo trapezio elicottero mi vai
charles perfetto ora sono in mano
distrae distrae
remote combat tv broadcast mette un mega
televisore con 106 siamo strumenti
viarie
ma cosa sta stringendo la prima è
bellissimo ma no tutto chiaro
comunicazione in questo bravo board
engine room ragazzi vediamo cosa devo
fare per disabilitare il motore non
farti agate charles ti va bene non può
essere un motorino così tutta con
astronave faccio io è uso il calibro ha
funzionato ho accelerato il processo per
dire level 2 drive lo avevano gridato
oppure con un pesce rosso bravo allora
usiamo il suop sono sia gli strati swap
play seguite di onenote i gadget vanno
sempre a minchia non funziona non
funziona niente e ti vuole roba lì rock
e clivio di rissa che ti fix the angel
the trainer bari grazie charles on the
left i tells the spread knight dei miei
miglia corri vaie ricorso te l'ho
picchiato io scala crati e vabbè casa
una macchina amici o conflitto che spero
mi sia piaciuto questo era il penultimo
episodio di harry stickman come al
solito vi piace anche per i soci alcuni
data notizia la nostra tesi di schede è
bella ragazzi
[Musica]